hey guys i'm 24 and my sister invited me
to her party that she's throwing at her
house
i'm a bit nervous because i'm too old to
be here
but here i
am going downstairs guys i feel so
old oh my god
guys i tried to leave the party i tried
to leave the party
i just came up here to do youtube
guys she needs to come downstairs and
hang out with me
how's the party scale of one to ten like
uh
[Music]
all right guys i'm about to play my
first game of purple
[Applause]
[Music]
all right y'all we're at the final
countdown we've got one
we got it all right
all right let's see if he gets there
not quite not quite i just kicked my ass
what do you guys have to say that's a
champion
it's a new era and all these are out of
there
all right guys that was a terrible
defeat um
especially because i'm not drinking
right that just makes it worse i lost
worse i lost to drunk kids um
i'm in the kitchen feeling sorry for
myself
[Music]
we're having plenty of time
all right we're going upstairs guys i'm
too old to be here